R
OS STORYASAYED
IN THESCBL
FAMIK  NEVER ACTUALLY A HIMD IN
HIS VIEW TRICKED HIMO A VATORSHG
>> ReporteIC ORR,
IND  S T THE CENTER O
HOLLYWOO
>> TEAM IS YOUR FAMILY, MICHAEL,
YOPROTECM.
YOU PROTECT HIS BLIND  YOU LOOK
>> YES, 'A
>> Reporter: IT,
NFL PLAYEALLEGING HE
WAICD BY SEAD LEIGH
FOOTBALLHY, BELIINHE 18-YEAR-O
>> Reporter: WHEN IN FACT, THEY
S
QUOTE, HCONTROL OVERORR'S
NEGOTIATFO E
CONTRACT, DESP
O
HAD NO PHYSICAL OR
PSYCHOLOGICAL LITIES.
ITORR SAYS, HE
DISCOVERED IN FEBR.
>> NEVERAD ONE BEFORE.
>> WHAT, ROO YOURSELF? A B
>> Reporter: OR S LIFE STORY
FROM POVERTY SL STARDOTHE SUPPOL
LLING .
N OSWIFILM, RTEDLY NETTIVE
MILLION. NONNEYEARS
LATER IS ASKING TH A ACCOUNTING.
THE SUITEA O CLASSMATES
SAW MICHL SIA
IN NEED,S SE ANDE SAG
ELSE, A GUIB M A LOCAL
TEWE DIDONEY OFF THE MOVIE."
DIDN'T MAKE HIM RICH. E  SOME MT
>>0 GRAND THE COURSE OF FIVARS
UT PAYMENTLY STATED HEBOUT
DOESN'T LI HE WAS
PORTRAYEIN THE MHIIGYORTRAYED
O READ OR E. GO INTO A LOCKER R
YOU CAN A PLAYBOOK, THAT
WEIGHS HEAVYepte TUOHYY THEY
HAVELISETTING TO
OF CHILDE ANY MONEY
GOING TO LOVLOVED HI
WHY THE SUITS HAPPENCHAEL JUST I
ABOUT THIS CONSERVATORSHIP IN
QUESTIONS WE PROPOSED TO HISATT
BAE  VERY EMENH THEIRNG THAT
ORR TRIED TO SKEHE FOROINGLI
A
IN PART,EA THAT THT TO
PROFIT OFF MR. INO
TO HAVE TO RESLO STEP IS T GOIN
INSTUT CRT SEEHOIS
AS YOU KNOW, AIP  ESTATE ANDATEY
ISUSE A PERSON
HAS BEENMEINCAPACITATED,
O S OR
HER OWN FINANCIAL OR
HD
N ERVATORSHIP
INSTEAD OF ADOPTED UNTIL  OF THI
DOES SURPRIS THEG RT
RERDESENT AT THE HEARING WHEN T
CO L TRANSCRIPT  THAT.ECOME HI
BUT IT IS SURPRISING THAHE KNO
T THE TEND O18 ANY OTHER REASONN
THIS CASE,
TUOHYS HAVE DONE SOMETHINGNG
HEREN TERM THE TORSHIP, WE ACTUY
T
AS THE PARENTS,THARDIANS, OCONE
INL. THOUGH I HAT NEEDED TO DO O
ABLE TO RESEAR WHETHER THAT WAAE
INNOCENT REASONS WHYY VATORSHIPL
IN HIGH SCHOOL.
>> DO THE ING
E DOES SEEM TO B EVIDENCE THAT O
DID R
FROM THE WHICH MADE MORE
TH0 I HAVESE EVIDENCE HAMO
WHAT DYOIT?>>HTLLUAY, THE ONCE .
THEY NEVER TOOK E OATH
ACTUALLY LEGAL AUTHOTYO SEE.WHIE
ACT ON MR.EH B
WITH HIS OWN THAT JUSTE YEARS LA